Charlie Kirk has this tweet a year after
Elon Musk bought Twitter he finally
explains why he says that the niche
ideology that turned San Francisco into
a zombie apocalypse would historically
be geographically isolated and the
Fallout would therefore be limited but
Twitter gave that philosophy an
information technology weapon which it
could use to spread mind virus to the
whole planet unopposed in order for the
Mind virus to propagate it must suppress
opposing viewpoints Rogan says because
it doesn't stand up scrutiny and musk
says correct I'll just play the clip for
you it's two minutes long You' you've
owned X for a year now the C oh yeah
yeah do you do you ever wake up in the
middle of the night and have a dream
that you didn't do
it and your life is infinitely easier
well it's certainly
um a recipe for trouble I suppose
or contention um what was it ultimately
that led you to make the decision to do
it I mean this is going to sound uh
somewhat melodramatic but I was worried
about that that it was having a
corrosive effect on
civilization uh that it was uh just
having a bad a bad impact it still is
and
um I think part of it is that it's where
it's where it was located which is uh
you know downtown San Francisco um and
while I I think San Francisco is a
beautiful city and and we should really
fight hard to um kind of write the ship
of San Francisco if you've walked around
downtown San Francisco right near the
xfk Twitter headquarters it's a zombie
apocalypse I mean it's rough have you
have you been been in that area not
lately no I've heard it's crazy I've
heard it's crazy I've heard you you
really can't believe it until you
actually go there you can't believe it
until you go there so now you have to
say well what philosophy led to that
outcome and that philosophy was being
piped to
Earth so um you know a philosophy that
would be ordinarily quite Niche and
geographically constrained so the that
sort of the fallout area would be
limited um was effectively given an in
weapon um mhm a tech Information
Technology weapon to
propagate uh what is essentially a m
virus to the rest of Earth um and the
outcome of that mine virus is very clear
if you walk around the streets of
downtown San Francisco so I mean really
hits the nail in the head if you look at
San Francisco the human feces everywhere
the the ridiculous real estate prices
it's a it's a it's a wasteland of failed
policy but because so much information
control was centralized there
Information Systems it was piping that
that I would I would call it like feal
data yeah the the equivalent of feces in
data form into the brains of people and
it was just melting their brains and
tainting them with the Mind virus you
look at San Francisco and you can see
that ideology is and has been popping up
all over this country he's he's Elon is
trying to shut down I still think he's
got a long way to go beyond that there's
also just failed governmental policy
that plays a huge role in that if we're
looking at Das who aren't Prosecuting
violent crime people who are uh like dep
I'd actually be interested to know what
your position is as a Libertarian is uh
uh on go ahead but this is this is be
it's the policy is because of social
media it's it's it's it's the ideology
people getting elected that it was it
was the Free Speech wing of the Free
Speech party and then it turned into a a
campus safe space for a bunch of whiny
baby Millennials but look at look at
who's opposing Le on musk now uh he's
getting a he's gotten a lot of push back
from the woke cartel as I call it uh and
one of the major push backs he's getting
is from the ADL I mean he had to sue
them because they really wrecked his
business at the F in the beginning
ruining his advertising base pulling all
these advertisers out now what that what
is that about so we're looking at this
mind virus uh is in the establishment
and it includes trying to squelch speech
and it includes critical discourse about
some very serious issues and groups like
The ADL that have all of this kind of
power in the system because they're
automatically perceived by anyone who
isn't aware of what's going on as a net
force for positive good in the world
when we know that it's been weaponized
time and time again against various
people who just happen to have ideas
that they disagree with so so you you
were a leftist professor yes I was and
you you broke out of this because you
said the left traumatized you yeah they
traumatized me what did they do um they
came after me I I started criticizing
all this social justice woke stuff on
campus for example they uh the the no
platforming you know the uh bias
reporting hotline that was a big one
they instituted this like reporting spy
system in which the students could
report on you for making a a woke
infraction you know what they call a
bias infraction and I thought it was
like a sty State system and I I spoke up
about it I would not put the the phone
number or the uh the email address on of
this biased reporting hotline on my on
my syllabi okay so they and then I I was
interviewed I started this uh Twitter
account it's now been cancelled uh
before uh Elon took over but I can't get
it back it was called anti-pc NYU Prof
and I started tweeting criticisms all
this from the standpoint of a professor
at NYU was interviewed and Twitter
banned you not yet not yet mean they did
ban it they eventually banned this
profile yes they did wow yeah and I
haven't been able to revive it even
after elon's takeover but then uh I did
this interview and I criticize all this
stuff publicly and within two days the
dean uh calls me into the office coerces
me into a leave of absence the diversity
Equity inclusion group condemns me I get
a bunch of blistering emails from
faculty saying that I was uh alt-right
Nazi uh short pants white devil all
kinds of ludicrous things racist sexist
the whole Manards anti-gay now today I
would just you know what I'd write back
is
LOL but then I actually cared what these
people thought just remember the people
tearing down the people tearing down
those photos of of the israelies were to
actually be the ones calling you a Nazi
probably back then so yeah they would
well so at the time what did you do you
were an apology or something oh no no I
started I wrote Springtime for
snowflakes for one okay and I stood up
to them and uh I eventually sued them I
sued NYU and five professors that were
libeling me all through the uh official
NYU list serves and eventually they said
you know they settled with me you know
how I got them to settle you'll love
this uh they threw out the uh Mo they
filed a motion to dismiss the case and
my lawyers could not overtake this uh
huge Army of attorneys that NYU had so I
invited Milo yannopoulos to speak in my
classroom listen to this on Halloween
itself okay and the topic of the of the
talk was going to be how you're not
allowed to wear a Halloween costume for
one night but you can change your gender
by day okay that was the topic and they
shut it down guess this B deasio
actually intervened and shut down my
classroom himself whoa yeah how how did
what did he do he he called NYU and said
this is tooo dangerous for to take place
now of course we know the danger was
coming from antifa who actually put a
Target on my back and through Twitter
were threatening to kill me wow I've
been told that antifa is not even a real
thing it's not even a real oh it's just
an idea it's just an idea it's an idea
that's in a lot of people's heads to
make them act like antifa to what you
said though like what you went through
kind of circles the point of what you're
saying is like if you push back most
people don't have the resources to go
against groups like this which have
massive budgets endowments whole groups
you know cadas of lawyers to back up
this I touched the third rail that there
was significant power behind that and I
realized at that point that this social
justice or what we now call wokeness was
really the power this was embedded in
the power structure if everybody who is
uh currently facing a a criminal uh
proceeding pleaded not guilty the system
would collapse really yeah the system
relies on uh people taking plea Bargains
and so that's that's why they the system
in my view is completely
unconstitutional it's the are you fam
with the jury tax or the trial tax
people call different things the idea
being that they will always say to you
whatever whatever it is you've committed
you're getting the maximum right you
know it's like oh you you uh you were
speeding that's you know you were going
20 you're going 30 over the limit that's
that's felony territory you're getting a
year in prison and we're going to make
sure that when you're convicted you get
it or plead guilty accelerates the
process so they can funnel more people
through because they don't it's
impossible to act well it's because
nobody wants to do the work and so this
is a huge failure of our system it's
supposed to be difficult and expensive
to make sure we uphold justice but you
see we got a lot of people who don't
want to deal with it they're lazy I
don't know you I don't care used to be
that if a cop stopped you and I mean
like early days of cops people knew the
cop in their neighborhood or get a
sheriff you know or a constable I guess
and they knew people and and social
scrutiny played a role in whether or not
they would be abusive most cops don't
even live in the area absolutely and so
when uh Co happened and a Tillis gym
stayed open the local cops said have a
nice day everybody so they pulled in
cops from a different city who said
we're now going to start putting the
boot on your neck yeah this is why I in
my campaign is a promotion of
localization and
decentralization to rest control from
the central government vested in the
people at the local level and then
nullify unconstitutional laws and
are
coming yeah how many departments cabinet
level departments would you get rid of
if you want cabinet oh that's that's
nice I get to the cabinet level
departments after I get rid of the IRS
the CIA the ATF the uh the FBI uh of
course the FED here we go Etc the first
one the fed the FED is obviously the big
monster okay but it's not as easy to get
rid of is is just go in and act it you
have to get an act of Congress but in
the meanwhile we can erode its power by
promoting parallel currencies Bitcoin
Etc uh and that means you rest the power
away from this money monopolist and you
use currencies on your own in the local
communities or across communities this
rods their power base as a monopolist
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 P.M
and become a member over at
timcast.net
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time